well jesse jesse do you have a question
for sarah
burbank right crazy
this thing is amazing it really is it's
kind of neat i don't know if your
podcast i love your podcast your podcast
is is uh
it was surprising to me because i feel
like it's like you call into a therapist
you know well it became that first of
all
in my internal monologue right now it's
going like i'm being not funny at all
like no but you're interested
you're really interesting and you're
both really interesting you don't have
to do you feel uh pressure to be funny
i don't but then sometimes i look back
and i go oh my god i was uh
only earnest that whole interview i
wasn't like goofy at all like i just i
have different heads and i
so so with the
with my podcast i planned on it being
like silly and dumb and fun and loose
and
these calls just got more and more
serious and then i would want to take
them because they were interesting or i
felt like i've been around long a long
time and i had something i had an
insight on that or i had a you know
but isn't there some and for both of you
isn't there some kind of
the onus is off of you to constantly be
to be funny it's
we like being funny and we like getting
a laugh and you like to hear the
immediate reaction but also i i like
communicating and i like learning and i
like you know kind of
you know i don't think we i learned that
really late in my career deal or no deal
was the first time was a was the most
embarrassing thing i've ever done in my
life and i was about to leave the
business and i've told the story many
times
but what happened was when i went on the
stage there i was face to face with
somebody whose life was going to change
hugely by even a small amount of money
you know the first woman i thought you
meant meghan markle
yeah
[Laughter]
you know and then i felt like obligated
to not distract with comedy and i
started talking to them like i which
they made fun of me on saturday night
live like i talked to you when you were
five years old i'd go it's 60
000
and i just wanted you to [ __ ] take
the money
because you live in iowa that's a down
payment on the house that's your journey
and they would go no deal so and i just
wanted everybody to leave
better i just felt like that was real
life it wasn't like doing jokes
and i was so embarrassed after the
taping
of the first five shows i flew to the
caribbean and didn't want to be seen
didn't want to see on tv you were with
me right yeah and we were in tortola and
i got a call going you know
20 million people watched last night the
next night was more next time so it's
the biggest success side of my career
it's the only time i did no jokes
i hired writers i had jokes but i was
afraid to distract the person i had no
jokes i had no but it worked because but
so does this talking to you like
especially with a podcast like this
platform where you're not really tied
down and it's yours that's the thing
that people gravitate to and love is
just you being authentic you're not
trying to do something different and
we've talked about this even on our
podcast where we get comments and stuff
and do this or we don't like that and
he's like i don't care i just want to do
what i like doing and whoever wants to
come along for the ride
great so i don't think you always have
to be funny and that's why people
gravitate towards i have to tell you
that this is you're very both very
interesting today and and i think
no but you don't have to be funny
but
talking along those lines you're also
not necessarily just on your podcast
you're very political
yeah are you not worried um and i'm not
talking about the the specific policies
or people but we live in a time now that
is it it seems to have opinion
weaponizes it's polarizing it's
polarizing but it's not just
everything's polarizing everything the
pronoun everything doesn't matter what
it is it doesn't matter what it is
[Music]